this movie is about competitive bird
watching Hollywood is truly run out of
ideas there's going to be major fallout
in a few hours
nuclear fallout bird fallout the big
year is directed by the director of The
Devil Wears Prada that stars Steve
Martin Jack Black and Owen Wilson it's a
movie about three guys competing to see
who can spot the most bird species in
one year that's the plot it's kind of a
departure from The Devil Wears Prada
which I thought was a good movie - this
kind of silly half family half more
older 50 60 year old men audience
demographic seriously I don't know
whether they were grabbing 30 what
killed your marriage - Stefano Surrey
first of all I was married to Bridget
no.3 January 1st I'm out of here you
realize the phase after retirement looks
a little bit like this
oh you're quick work yeah great talking
to you it's told from the perspective of
Jack Black's character and it's him it's
his dream to be this the ultimate
birdwatcher man and received the trophy
of I've spotted the most Birds Owen
Wilson's characters that holds the
record of the guy who spotted the most
Birds ever in a year Steve Martin is a
guy who's really into it too and from
the trailer I was like really a
bird-watching movie and I was just like
you know I'm just gonna shut up because
this could be one of those movies is
just absolutely hilarious and surprises
you on every level and you know
unfortunately it really is I just want
to do something big you know we need a
little adventure you're doing a big year
a year to do all the things we never
could it's not a horror movie it's not a
bad movie it's not a great movie and
it's not even a good movie it's just
like in the middle or you just kind of
you have some laughs in the film and
there's some parts of the movie that are
entertaining and there's some good
messages behind the movie there's it has
good messages from trying to say hey
there's good things under the surface
where a person would be like oh yeah
that's nice that's really nice and so
but the movie itself you just don't
really care I mean it's a movie about
bird watching that is something that a
very few amount of people on this earth
strive to do is spot as many print
species in a year so because of that
then we should be able to make you
really care for that event but it
doesn't really know they could be
exhausted by the race to the bottom
they're turning their quest commandeer
they ever stopped competing they died
into the ultimate competition
this is my year I'm gonna make my mark I
think it's trying to be like a really
relentlessly entertaining fast-moving
fun comedy and it just doesn't really
deliver those laughs that you would
think would be in a movie with Jack
Black and Steve Martin and Owen Wilson I
mean come on these are three comic
heavyweights I like all three of those
guys and I've seen good movies from all
three of them but lately Jack Black
hasn't been in much I mean you can argue
Kung Fu Panda 2 he was a voice in that
you know Steve Martin hasn't been in a
movie since it's complicated in 2009 and
Owen Wilson this year is had Cars 2
which you know Wow but he also had
Midnight in Paris which was great but
this one is more in line that's kind of
what he's been producing over the past
four years just kind of just in the
middle it doesn't have too many laughs
but it has a good heart behind you feel
like they're trying to tell you
something good can't miss the flight
there's not another one for a week it
sucks for him cooking no it's not like a
movie that you just sit there and you're
like please and now it's nothing that
you're like I can't wait to see what
happens next
Wow they saw a grey spotted owl it's not
like that the big year is not a terrible
movie it has good things in it Jack
Black is funny Steve Martin is funny
lone Wilson is funny it's just that the
movie isn't that funny you know there
was an emotional side and there's a
funny side and it just didn't really it
wasn't cohesive and I feel bad because
you know these are 300 I like and I want
to see Emma be that they're in succeed
it was okay it was alright it was no
payphone so I'm gonna give the Big Ear a
C+ this is incredible isn't it unless
there's a freak blizzard I shouldn't
have said there's gonna be a freak
lizard jinx
if you liked my review you can subscribe
to my channel and get stuck my eyes